I want matches and candles Mercier
paloto and her daughter Joyce are on a
tight budget right now they can only
afford to spend thirty dollars on
groceries they're only buying Basics the
family can't do without
but the price of some essential Goods in
Zimbabwe have gone up again that means
they're taking home list this month than
they did the last
there is nothing we can do things are
just too expensive we try and stretch
the little money we have so we can buy
more but it's never enough
the inflation rate is now more than 260
percent unemployment is high many people
with jobs have to supplement their
income by earning cash elsewhere Rising
prices in a weak currency mean more and
more people are being pushed into the
informal trade sector including Street
vending to make ends meet selling
anything from second-hand clothes to
groceries Zimbabwe's current economic
problems aren't as bad as they were in
the early 2000s then hyperinflation
reached record levels and the local
currency had no value and was completely
abandoned the Zimbabwe dollar was
reintroduced in 2019 but some economists
say things aren't looking good the more
they come of stability we're
experiencing at the moment the million
dollar question is to what extent can
you sustain that level of stability
for messiah and Joyce Zimbabwe's economy
isn't turning around fast enough the
groceries they bought have to last them
at least a month
and they're not sure they will just like
they're not sure about their country's
economic future harumutasa Al Jazeera
Harare